I have one more question for you because
I was like just looking up some random
facts online so for all I know this
isn't true but I read it that you had
interest in directing a Fantastic Four
movie and given the fact that we are at
a comic convention right now I'm curious
what your take on it was so that sort of
told this whole story last night it's a
long story it took maybe an hour of our
dinner I really thought that would be a
cool thing to do coming off of Lord of
the Rings and the the coolest thing may
not be what's cool well no actually you
guys would appreciate this the campaign
to get the job is what was amazing there
had been many screenplays over years
that the studio had developed including
Christopher Columbus had developed a
screenplay Chris Columbus at develop a
screenplay so I went and tracked down
and it's not as easy as it sounds where
those screenplays were so I could read
them so I could see what the evolution
of the the story that you know that the
studio was buying and it's a little bit
shocking like I actually think most of
the people in the convention could do a
better job of developing most of these
franchises than the studio executives
themselves because they and that they
probably think that too which is why
they're scouring you remember the last
starfighter
yes with Lance guys yeah so everybody in
here it's like this is these panels are
your video game test they are watching
they will come down out of the sky and
pluck young writers up to take you in
the Hollywood it doesn't hurt so but
they they'll base they'll come up with a
a writer will come up with a take or the
executive will have a take in the final
writer who really understands the
approach and then they'll hire them and
they send them out for a period of time
and then they get the the script back
and sometimes it bears no resemblance to
what was agreed upon and it's better or
it bears a lot of resemblance to what
was agreed upon and it's not very good
and then they start the process of you
know well we're gonna give you some
notes and then you will you know we'll
give you these notes and then you go
back and work on it for another month
and then you give it and it goes back
and forth like that and sometimes it's
just like riding one of those like a
broken toy horse outside of a shopping
cart it's like oh this isn't working but
um but on that one I went and I found
all of those screenplays and I really
tried I remember calling Chris Columbus
who is just on the whatever Harry Potter
v Harry Potter or something like that
and because he wrote The Goonies he took
my call and I said listen I really want
to direct this not really knowing that
he was slated to direct it for a period
of time and he shepherded that that I
don't know if he actually wrote the
draft that I wanted to look at I don't
think he did but it was in his control
1493 s control and and and he said well
you know I was they we had talked a lot
about me doing it and I was like wow are
you are you gonna do it and he said I
don't think so because the version I
want to make would cost two hundred
million dollars and I'm like yeah mine's
really about thirty million so give me
the script so but he he was kind enough
to let me I drove over to the studio I
got his script I read it when I went in
to meet with the the head of I called my
look my lawyer and the partner the head
partner in the firm was one of the most
important powerful lawyers in Hollywood
and Jake bloom and you could never even
if you're a client at the law firm
nobody talks to Jake he represented
Schwarzenegger when Schwarzenegger was
governor you know and all through the
terminators and stuff and I'm like Dave
I want to meet I want Jake to call Tom
Rothman the head of 20th Century Fox and
tell him that Sean Astin wants to direct
Fantastic Four and he was like you're
out of your flippin mind he goes if you
directed a feature like no not yet
it was like well I can't I was like I
want you to call him and I want you to
tell him and and I made it he could tell
how serious I was and so sure enough
Jake bloom called Tom Rothman and said
this kid Sean Astin wants to direct
Fantastic Four he's like kids out of his
flippin mind so he took a meeting to
he took a meeting oh and the other thing
I had done was I started flying myself
all over the world to the different
special-effects houses I went up to
Lucasfilm I went to Warner Brothers had
a big thing in in in London I went to
see obviously new New Zealand Lord of
the Rings I knew what their shop pretty
good so but I really wanted to make sure
that I was as up-to-the-minute as I
could possibly be on what was going into
making this film so and I had and the
other thing was I'd gotten a call back
from Kevin Fahey you know who that is is
the head of Marvel so he caught he
wasn't the head of it then he was had a
physical production then and he called
me because I was just starting in Lord
of the Rings so like there was a moment
where you could just call people and and
I said listen is there any way in the
world I would be you know that you'd
consider me to direct Fantastic Four and
he was like well I don't know and bla
bla bla I said are so are you saying
there's zero chance zero no chance 100%
not gonna do it he says well I'm not
gonna say 0% I'm like cool so I was
actually a Bauman's rare book dealership
in on Madison Avenue and I grabbed a
metamorphosis the book metamorphosis by
Ali metamorphosis Kafka thank you
Kafka $5,000 so I didn't buy I put it on
hold jumped in a cab went to Midtown
comics
I called Midtown comics and I'm like
every single I didn't know anything
about it I wouldn't have known anything
from Fantastic Four if you would have
liked if the characters would have
walked in front of me I would have no
idea who they were
but I just knew that it was America I've
been in New Zealand for two years and
this was America it was an American
concept of American heroes and and the
relationship between them and so I so I
said to the guy make town comics listen
I'm coming in I want to buy every single
thing in your comic book store that has
anything to do with Fantastic Four he
was like really I've started thinking
like there's gonna be some first edition
something that's a million dollars I
don't like
a million dollars but but I went in
there and I've got all this stuff and
I'm pouring through it and I remember I
was trying to meet with Christina
Aguilera I thought she'd be great as Sue
Storm I was doing I was I was it was an
amazing time it was like it was an
insane time but I so I go in to meet Tom
Rothman and he looks at me and he's like
what are you doing here I said I want to
direct this movie feels all right well
this meeting is premature we've ordered
another script it's due in three weeks
from now and he said and all and and
I'll let you read it I said if you I
said if I have your commitment do I said
do I have your commitment that if that I
get to read that and have a meeting with
you before you set the director please
can I have that commitment he said I
give you that commitment because Jake
Bloom had called him and those are
powerful guys so I was like dude so I
get this call you can come in tomorrow
at 5:00 p.m. go to Rupert Murdoch's
office and you can sit at his desk and
read the new draft so I showed up at
4:00 waiting and I get in there and I
read it and and this is kind of
instructive for anybody who wants to be
a writer or be a filmmaker or work in
studios at all or anybody's interested
in it when I met with the younger
executive before I met with hutch Parker
who was the president of the studio and
so forth he was I was telling him that
my not my my short film was nominated
for an Academy Award and I and I did
this and I did that and I did the other
thing and he was like nobody cares he
goes all they care about is do you know
what we should do with this character or
do you know what should happen at this
point in the story like why isn't the
story working better here if you can
help us make the movie better on its own
terms that's what we really need so and
that was like so liberating so then I'm
sitting at Rupert Murdoch's desk and I'm
reading the script and like I went into
the script my whole like my creative
mind went into the script and I and I
like I got it I got what they were going
for and I got what
wrong with it really clearly don't know
if I can remember it now but so the next
morning I go in to have my meeting with
him and Tom Rothman says he says well
okay I said well I said you have he the
way he's the way he did the chit chat I
don't know whatever was but I said well
do you have a question we hadn't even
started talking yet he goes yeah how
about the big one why you I said before
they'll put some 24-year old kid in a
hundred million dollar fighter plane
they put him in the best trainers
simulators ever designed I said from the
time I was 12 years old I've been in the
best simulators you could possibly have
for this kind of thing and he goes oh
okay
right so then we started talking and I
said well this is what I think here and
this is what I think there and then he
got up and he started pacing and he was
listening to me and he was like but what
about this and we just had like a real
creative conversation about what was
going on with a with a story and where
they had to rip and they he was really
he was like he was impressed he not just
impressed like what you're an impressive
human being but like the ideas that I
was presenting him were impressed in his
mind he wanted he liked them and then
and then I went to this to a to a boxing
match with Chiklis with Michael Chiklis
and we went out afterwards like I don't
even know how this happened and I'm like
you got a play thing he's like well I
don't know I'm like you can't I was like
that part came down from God for you you
have to play this part there is no one
else on planet earth you can play I was
like do you know who's waiting to see
this this be done do you know the
audience that's that wants you to do
this right now and I think I talked him
into it I don't know if you would
remember this conversation at all but
I'm pretty sure I talked about I tried
to talk Cameron Diaz into playing Sue
Storm but she was like wait how long do
I have to be in the makeup and I was
like well you know maybe a WoW is it
yeah no I don't want to do that so I got
this call my mom and I were in DC we
just been lobbying on Capitol Hill for
more funding for National Endowment of
the Arts or something and my phone rings
and I just knew
I just knew and I kind of looked down I
open it hi this is whatever we have Tom
Rothman for you and I I go OK he said
Shawn it's Tom I say
hey Tom cuz I hope you can hear the good
and what I'm about to say and I was like
he goes when Jake Bloom called me and
told me that you had never directed a
feature and you wanted director
fantastic for I told him you were out of
your mind he said I I never I didn't
know you hadn't heard of you you weren't
on my radar at all he said but I want to
tell you something you forced me to take
you seriously as a filmmaker he said so
you may not have been on my radar before
but you'll be on my radar now and and
and you know I said well I'll be first
in line to watch the movie so that's
that story